oh
[Musique]
à londres où conter l'histoire des
aventures de deux aventures nous allons
vous conter l'histoire les inventer
peu de now
cette histoire me démontrer
accor % pas mal
thil sap
cela
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
mais je ne me trompe pas c'est hier
seule main que dieu vous protège vous
est l'âme de votre père en quelle fameux
chanteur c'était le meilleur chanteur de
france partie mais vous même il me
semble vous faisiez de la musique le
plaisir que j'ai à vous rencontrer se
doublerait si vous consentiez à me
chanter une petite ritournelle à comment
trouvez vous la prenez pas mal pas mal
mais ne pouvait vous monter plus haut
un assez joli en effet continuer
continuer je vous en prie seulement je
pouvais réunir en un même repas le
fromage et le chanteur
votre fromage qui vient de tomber
m'apporte une odeur insupportable et moi
qui me suis rompu la jambe dans un
maudit piège non loin d'ici je ne puis
le déplacer chercheurs seul un je vous
en prie descendez me délivrer de cette
abomination
hâtez vous mon cher
n'ayez rien à craindre de moi qui suis
impotent
un traître j'aurais dû m'en douter et
bien garde de ce fromage je te
l'abandonnent
[Musique]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]